It's time for Drew's News,
your good news umbrella in a rainy news storm,
and with me at the desk is my cozy cup of soup
on a rainy day, Rosy Ross Mathews.
I'ma warm you up.
(audience cheers)
Hi everybody.
Okay, rock your story.
I have a story you are not gonna believe Drew.
Newsweek reports a woman on Reddit
confessed that she swapped her wife's mean cat
for a different cat.
(Drew and audience laugh)
A nice cat and to this day, her wife has no idea.
I couldn't believe that she claimed it happened back
when they were dating.
I heard then girlfriend was out of town
and she went over to feed her black cat
and the cat like scratcher to smithereens.
So, she went to the shelter.
She got a nicer black cat.
(audience laughs)
Found a home for the other black cat.
And now six years later, the wife has no idea.
(audience laughs)
I think this is totally naughty
and I'm not really big on lies in relationship.
Yeah.
And this one feels like a pretty big one.
But it's like meet the parents,
but nobody ever finds out
jinxy cat isn't like the painted tail rescue.
Like how did you not know that wasn't your cat?
I have three chihuahuas, if you replace one,
it'd be like, "Cute chihuahua, where's mine?"
(Drew and audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
Two thumbs up.
Thanks Drew.
Well we're a pair of hopeless romantics at this desk.
And we like to keep our antennas up for fun new ways
to find love.
(Ross and audience laughs)
Today, we've got a modern take
on the old school personal ad.
The New York Times reports
HotSingles is a weekly email newsletter
that drops a new Hottie in your inbox every week.
It's put together by Rhonda Cicala
and you can subscribe for free.
You'll meet eligible singles like Plant-Based Princess
looking for a Romaine-tic partner.
Yes, you did.
(audience cheers)
Let us applaud.
Or this CitiBike Boi looking for a CitiBike Bae
to take him for a ride.
Okay.
Each ad includes a photo and a Q&A
to get to know your Hottie a little better.
It's funny 'cause hot singles gives me
like sort of young trendy, like sexy vibes.
And I feel like this is a little bit more old world,
a little more patient, a little more thoughtful.
This is not the boom.
So HotSingles, like the name doesn't kind of measure up
to the sort of old worldliness of being patient,
waiting weekly, responding in the letter, personal ads.
Yeah, can I ask you some questions
that you could answer in this HotSingles ad?
Sure.
Okay, what are you looking for in a partner?
Someone who can be nice every day.
Oh, that's good.
(audience claps)
And I wish things for everybody.
Yeah, I have to say if I wasn't engaged
and if straight.
(audience laughs)
I mean those are a couple of big hurdles,
but we could have really get it off.
Really something could've happened here.
(audience claps)
As they say in real estate,
there's always gonna be some bad.
Okay, here's the most interesting question.
What is your most toxic trait?
What's the red flag of you?
Flag, I really am hard on myself like toxically.
So the inner dialogue is corrosive.
I'm like you are so good to other people
and then you get to yourself
and it's just like, no room for air.
Can I challenge you to something?
Please.
Next time you're spiraling on yourself,
will you just say to you,
"Drew, I'm gonna treat you as well as you treat Ross."
Because you are so good to me.
You are, you're so kind.
You're so loving and you're so sweet.
So if you wouldn't say it to me, don't say it to...
(audience claps)
I love you.
That's a good challenge, take it.
And I have to tell you Ross,
if anyone ever messed with Rossy.
Oh, look at that face.
(audience laughs)
I will take you down.
(Ross and audience laughs)
Okay, so Reddit is really good for cat confessions,
but it turns out it's also good for planning a worm party,
Yes, romper.com reports that one mom wrote in
to a Reddit post title,
daughter insists on worm-themed birthday.
Okay.
And she got flooded with suggestions
on how to make her whimsical worm party
of her five-year-old's dreams.
People shared dirt cake ideas
with little gummy worms inside of them.
And we did our own digging
and found out worm dogs.
Those are like hot dogs
that look like you're eating little worms.
Oh, okay.
We also found worm pizza,
worm dirt cups for dessert.
It's just chocolate.
Yeah, just like ground up cookies.
It's a pudding.
Yeah and then pudding in the middle.
(audience laughs)
And look, we even found you some worm balloons.
Cute with the little googly eyes, look.
(audience cheers)
(audience claps)
Cute, well from worms to workplace,
this is interesting.
A new survey finds that the highest performing teams
at the office are the teams
who are having the most fun.
Insider reports a survey of 1000 workers
found the most productive teams
were also most likely to be joking around,
sharing gifs and emojis, swearing together.
Oh, I would be...
If swearing led to anything, I would excel at it.
Yes you would.
(audience claps)
You're a winner.
You do.
(audience claps)
I love swearing, I love it so much.
Well, they also say not just swearing,
but gossiping makes you more productive too.
What?
For bosses, the survey found
that the number one thing you can do if you're a boss
to improve performance is to give credit
and recognize hard work.
There's nothing bad that comes out of telling people
that they're doing a good job.
(audience cheers)
But I do love that people who swear and have fun.
This is my best news ever.
And then on the gossip front and information
in pop culture and all exciting tidbits, well guess what?
Michelle Turner, my amazing friend
from Entertainment Tonight,
she's gonna come out here right after the break
and tell us all about all the moments with stories.
(upbeat music)